how's it going bros this is beer to
power and welcome to a brand new how-to
series where we're going to cover
anything from how to be an alcoholic to
how to ride a Zeppelin now Tyler Oakley
[Music]
appears everywhere even places where I
don't think he's supposed to be ah Dan
and Phil YouTube's power couple I mean
YouTube power duo what are these two
have in common with me Wow they're both
releasing book at the same month and I
thought hey that's cool but apparently
no it's not I've been told that it's a
competition and that I need to beat them
but the thing is I don't stand a chance
and you may think hey my channel is
bigger I'll be fine but they have
something that I don't fangirls a
ton of fangirls
how do I get more fangirls I need
fangirls to compete fangirls will buy
all the merch fangirls is the key to
merch don't believe me just look at
Alfie and you may think hey puts you
have fangirls come on no look at my
statistics
so I asked the internet for help let's
see what you came up with how to align
upbeat lee swedish accent and saying
words in swedish will get you fanger
[Music]
okay that is various I can even do with
my own accent my accent is a little bit
of everything going on you know all
right
or there are gonna be more fangirls now
watching yeah
perhaps laptop valve
Co regos take off your shirt and show
those two babies on your arms
works every time this is Mathilda and
this is Lisa they're both equally
pathetic Papa died return andis show us
your smolder now I didn't know what a
smaller was so that shows just how far
behind I this is a smolder
[Music]
is it working
hot dog Jonas Mills melons top floor
Kenickie Hendrix wink a lot is just
getting stupid I'm not gonna sink that
low
thank you very very much
Mitch Wetzler sing a song that doesn't
target out a single feature you like
about a girl I can do that
[Music]
Leigha crews harass change hair colors
is it working
you look good at least this is special
effects Department doing a good job
right now ha
okay for the final advice is from James
hem be pity pi but don't look like him
done alright you know what I get it
I'll I'll never get enough fangirls I'll
never get enough book sales but you know
what at least I have my integrity in
mystical time to get out of committee
all right price this video was obviously
a joke if you like Tyler Oakley then buy
his book and if you like Dan and Phil
then buy their book and if you like my
book buy two of them so we can beep okay
no more jokes seriously though don't buy
my book I like everyone I like honestly
everyone else's services more so don't
buy my book it's reverse psychology I'm
gonna end the video before you realize